And there's a history to boxing
know that unfortunately, you know,
because I care about the sports for
my whole life. Um, that it's kind of,
yeah, it's got a reputation as being
correct. Yeah. And unfortunately,
fortunately, and unfortunately,
like there's a part,
the good part where the history goes back
longer, farther than any other sport,
any other sport. I mean, it was
the first sport in the Olympics,
it goes back further. And it was
the biggest sport in this country,
bigger than baseball. At one time
it was that big. I mean, you know,
so and now it's, it's not,
and it, it's too bad because,
and it's too bad that the
kids, that the younger people,
they don't have the ability
to learn about those fighters.
So special fighters that were
special, they really want,
and it was special for
different reasons. Like,
like Jackie Robinson was special. We know,
we don't have to go into why he was
special, but nobody knows that Joe Lewis,
who is quiet and everything, but when
he was in the army and there was,
you know, segregation and
all that crap going on, he,
he quietly used his position
as heavyweight champ of
the world to make sure that
when he went to movies and they put him
in the front row and he saw that blacks
weren't allowed to come in. He said,
I'm not going in there unless
blacks can come in there.
When he went to other sort of events
where the same kind of junk was going on,
he very quietly but powerfully
integrated things and said, no, I'm
going to make a change here. You, you,
you're not going to have me and
not have people that look like me,
you know, kept out. So he, I never,
people I've read about it because
I like reading about those things,
about history, um, to see how
we can be better and, and um,
where we've come from.
And there were history of
black families, you know,
poor black families that would,
would get hope from just saying, Hey,
Luiz did it. They would tell
their kids, Hey Joe, listen,
I don't want to hear this. I don't
want to hear that. You can't do this.
Joe Lewis did it. And so he
was that important. That's all,
that's the only point I'm
making here. He was that
freaking important that that history and
the history of other fighters like him
doesn't have to be black fighters,
but that what they fo what
they did, what they overcame,
where they came from,
who Benny Lennon. Um,
one of the greatest Jewish fighters of
all time. There was a time when, uh,
and it's still around, unfortunately
there's a lot of antisemitism,
but there was a time where, you
know, it was tough being a Jew and,
and you're growing up and
he get caught on kike on,
on pronounce it right. I think
it was right. And you get caught.
All those kind of, I don't even
know what the hell that means.
I just know it's a bad
name to call ju. And,
and you had all that stuff going on and
jewels woman thought of being there were
thought of moving towards banking in the,
they moving towards things
will make them money into that.
Later on they started doing that but
they wouldn't have ghettos and they were
trying to pull themselves out. And
so at that era, during that time,
the twenties to thirties the truth was
some of the best fighters because that
was their way of getting out.
But there was [inaudible],
there was another significance to be
in a Julie's fighter that a lot of the
kids,
they won't be thought of as be in Tufts
or they got picked on and thought of
that they're going to go more
towards academic and other stuff.
So there was a weakness
perceived not true.
None of this stuff is
perceived but cause Mark. Yeah.
So now all of a sudden Betty
Lennon comes along when a sports,
the biggest sport in the country and
he's the best freaking fighter in a game.
And he combed his hair before he got in
a ring and he would come out without it
being messed. And this was,
this guy was, I mean he was,
he was Michael Jordan. I mean before
that stuff, before Michael joined,
before air Jordan [inaudible]. I
mean this guy was down only tough.
He was not only a champion,
which obviously connected
to being tough by itself,
but it was, he was smart.
He was, he was cool.
He had pazazz,
he was a man and there
were Jewish families.
You don't hear about these stories,
but there were Jewish families I've read
and I've heard from people where say,
Hey, don't let nobody pick on you.
Benny Leonard is the best fighter
in the world. Jews are tough.
We're, we're not just smart. We're tough.
Benny Leonard shows that.
So that kinda history,
that kind of
polling of people up
in many different ways,
not just economically out of
poverty, but, but emotionally,
mentally, because you can
be in poverty mentally.
You can be in the low place mentally.
It doesn't have to be, you know,
financially all the time.
You know where you have holes in your
shoes and you and you're wearing shirts
that don't fit now it can be the way you
feel about yourself that is without is
without Prince 30 with with without value.
You have no value for
yourself as a person.
That's the worst poverty
in the frictional world.
There's not the lower than that
and Joe Lewis and Benny Leonard,
they were fighters. They
weren't baseball players.
They pulled people out of those.
They let people know they had
value, that their race had value,
their people had value,
they had value and that should be known
and you can go anywhere and am glad you
can because I love all sports.
You can go anywhere and you can read about
the greatness of the baseball players
in a greatness of, of course NFL
hasn't been around that long,
but the greatness of those players
and the greatness of the NBA players,
but where do the kids ever get to
read and to hear and to see about the
greatness of these people,
these fighters? V nowhere,
very little. Very little.
It's not there. Why?
Because again, I'm not
going to get into craziness,
but the powers that be the, listen,
it's not marketed properly. I get it.
It doesn't have a commission so it doesn't
take care of itself the way the U of
C,
the greatness about the why the UFC grew
so much as they marketed themselves in
a tremendous way. So there's
nobody, boxing is just there.
It takes care of itself. It exists
because it's man against man.
So it's always going to be
there. But nobody's building it.
Nobody's marketing and Norman's
feeding them monster to make it bigger.
It's a plant that's in the corner of,
of of your offers that doesn't
get sun, doesn't get hot,
but it's still there. It's still there.
And what I'm saying is that
[inaudible] I didn't want to yell because
now people are probably happy but,
but, but it should be fed a little bit.
It should be watered a
little bit. But you know,
cause of what I just described it
guys like you call that guys like you
guys who have a deep appreciation for the
history of the sport guy,
guys who have a deep appreciation of
what it meant when Joe Louis beat max
Schmeling guys,
guys who understand what it meant when
sugar Ray Robinson was the best fighter
in the world and everybody knew when
he pulled up in a fucking pink Cadillac
with a beautiful suit on
and any any made the elevated,
he elevated people in Harlem
everywhere off. But Harlem, he had,
he owned half a Harlem.
He owned restaurants in [inaudible]
stores and barber shops and everything.
And, and you wanted to be there because
that's where his sugar Ray Robinson came
from. Yup, it was great. Yeah,
it's a rich part of history
that really does get ignored.
Let me tell you somewhere I was
Schmeling you brought up, you know,
love of obviously stuff
and that's why it's
nice to talk about which
smelling was a hell of a fighter.
Joe Lewis was the Brown
bomber who was coming up.
He was undefeated and I'm strolling,
had the great quote before the fight.
You know,
it's kinda like the babe Ruth thing that
they really happen where he pointed out
and then he hit on, you know, those,
those are great stories, but, but where,
what's the real truth behind them? You
know, we don't know. We don't care.
We don't care at a certain point, you
know why? Because they let us feel good.
They let us dream about possibilities
and we should all have possibilities to
dream about. And they make
somebody feel good because,
you know, the babe Ruth one
was connected to a sick kid.
So [inaudible] it's a nice thing.
It's where sports can be better
than just sports than just somebody
participating in it. It can go beyond
that. He agreed stronger than that.
And that's some of the
good stuff about it.
And so smelling the great story,
he didn't point to, you
know, the, to the fence,
but he said before the fight,
I see something with a, that's my, my, uh,
trying to be an accent
for the German, you know,
but I sound more like
Schultz from Hogan's heroes.
I don't know why every time you try to
do something, like with certain ethnic,
you know, pronunciations, um, you,
you sounded like you go to one of those
sitcoms, you go to one of those places,
you know, and when I say somebody, I
think my kid, I think my son said, uh,
you know, he had watched one of them, uh,
and I think he said he sounded like
Sergeant Schultz, like from Hogan's,
uh, heroes split. And he
said, I see something.
And what he saw was that Louis
would jab and he would leave.
You should never leave your head on a,
on a right side because if
you leave your head, you know,
you move your head to the right side,
you're in a path to the right hand,
you should actually finish on the left
side because then you outside the right
hand, you follow. There's
the right man over here.
It can hit you outside.
Right? So he had a habit of,
and he had a great trainer.
He had a habit though at that point
of leaving his head over on the right.
So smelling saw something as he said
that he could hit him with a right hand.
He could time it over the jam.
Now smelling was of the ilk
of the level of the caliber.
It wasn't just about talent. He
could punch it was a good fighter,
but it was a pro. What do I mean by that?
A lot of guys would hesitate
a little bit. Same opening.
They might see it, but it was the
Brown bomber was knocking everyone out.
So they hesitate. They
will. They were afraid.
Normal lot of people afraid of that word.
I mean it's there and
without it, we're not alive.
So he, they, they might
see the same thing,
but they want them at a pro level.
Pro level is a guy that can do what he
has to do and no emotions interfere with
doing it. I mean that's my simplest
way of Webster's might not say that,
but that's what I would say. So
they might've seen the opening,
but they would hesitate just enough
and it'd be gone the door close.
Cause it's, it's, it's like life. It's
moments capture moment, lose the moment.
And, but this guy was a pro. He,
he didn't let that come in there and
make them hesitate that, that fear,
he controlled it. And if
Goldman was there, bang,
he was going to throw the punch. So he
did and he dropped lose a few times.
And you know,
he won that fight and was
around the stop. The man,
I can't remember, maybe, maybe the
ninth, but it was late in the fight,
but he had heard them and you know,
Louis was taking a beating. So
Louis Lee went on, he won
no world title and um,
he'd be Bradick for the title
Cinderella man. Great movie. Yes. Maybe,
you know, he came from welfare
to be in a world champion.
That's the product story without
getting into it too much.
So are you a lose beats sporadic
and had to give a percentage,
you know, tanking and Aaron
might not been around then, but,
but the people that told them what
to do around taught them how to take
advantage of fighters, taught them how,
what options were before options
were ever known. You know, eh,
the Vladek I think, I forget his name,
but Braddock's manager basically made
Lewis and his people agree to give him a
percentage of his person for the rest
of his career to get the fight. Yeah.
Yeah. So I mean,
you could obviously research it and
look into how much percentage, Oh,
I don't know. I listened. I could say 10%,
but I don't want to say definitively
because I'm not positive, but,
but there was an understanding
that you know, you,
you're not getting a fight otherwise
you won't get the fight now. And listen,
like I said, you know, not great guys,
but King in Iram, uh, they,
they had other guys before them that
taught them some of these moves. Right.
You know, that Von is so nice,
but there's always a history
of good and bad. Sure. Always.
Who's good? Well, this, there's a
shining star promoter out there.
I'll try to think about it.
So we, so they go and they are,
he wins the title and of course
the biggest sport in the country.
So all the presses there and
there, Joel is the champion,
was not yet. Not yet.
What do you mean not yet?
Just one of the title. Not
yet. Not to. I beat that man.
He didn't even have to say his
name not to, I beat that man.
That's how much pride he had. And listen,
he's the real deal because it is mine.
How could I be champion of
a guy knocked me out? Right?
So when that fight took place, I mean,
you talk about ha, uh, setting
a stage, you know, the,
nowadays people say, Oh, I'm on a stage.
It's a lot of pressure, you know, Hey,
I'm not saying it's not, I'm not saying
it, but a lot of pressure, you know,
almost a lot of people look in, a lot
of people, you know, depending on, I,
I learned stuff going on,
you know, and I, you know,
maybe I got a headache,
but Joe Lewis had world
war two on horizon.
The president of the United States
called them up and you had Nazi Germany.
He had a guy named Hitler that that
is saying that he's got, you know,
the master race, it's going
to take over the world.
Just starting that stuff for not too far
away from world war II and you got all
that stuff permeating in the air
and you've got laws fighting.
A guy who of course, you know,
propaganda was started by the Germans,
if you want almost to me almost invented
that word because you had to propaganda
minister and you had all these terrible
people with Hitler that we're putting
out today.
The master race that is there that
you had to judge y'all win situation
Olympics. Yeah.
And now you had the biggest sport in
the biggest country and the champion of
that sport, the heavyweight
chair, Joe Lewis,
and he's fighting the German fighter
shearling the second time now for the
title. And of course you had
Hitler nor his psycho fans
or these people that were,
their job was to promote it, so to speak.
And they come and they're saying,
we will show the world that we're superior
and there's no better way to show it
then in a ring. And so Louis has to,
he's gotten, he's got to carry all
this stuff. I mean take about it.
And he's a black guy in a country that,
that he still can't go
into certain places.
T and he's got to carry the whole,
he's got to carry the whole
country and not let them down.
And the president calls, and again, we
don't know if there's a legendary story,
we don't know if it's completely true,
but supposedly the president called him,
said, Joe, you've got a windows
one for the good guys that that's,
that's one of the legends. I don't
know if it's true, but I know that,
I'm sure he called him,
I'm sure he called them
and Louis has to go into,
it's gotta go into Yankee stadium
outdoors and in times square in New York,
they used to have it set up where they
would do radio because all the fight one
radio back then and some
of them on fights, on TV,
on select cavalcade sports and all
that stuff. Fight and I fight. But was,
was common along, you know, to stop
coming along. But radio was the thing.
And so in times square you had
the radio speakers outdoors
[inaudible]
you know, playing a fight broadcast in
the fight. So people out on the streets,
they hear the radio and a a, you know,
Joe Lewis is walking into
the ring and you know, and,
and you've got the Yankee stadium,
you've got to place full and you've got
the whole world of everything I just
described. The good, the
bad, the evil, the ugly,
everything. It's not a
movie, it's real life.
And you got Joe Lewis and he
gets in that ring in here,
Nile with all this pressure, wood,
wood that, that he's got to save the,
basically the United
States in a world from,
from looking like this, this ugly
scorch and, and, and disease
of the Nazi party is,
is going to take over.
The world is greater than us and he and
he single handily has to prove that.
Okay.
And he, he goes in there and he
annihilates the guy in one round
[inaudible]
with all that stuff hanging over them.
I think that's the greatest single
event in the history of the world.
Pull that fighter, pull that fight
up and put it in the background.
And I think that diet,
when you talk about all the things
that we're here to talk about,
about character, about talent,
about presence, [inaudible],
about resiliency, about, about
caring, about more than yourself,
about selflessness.
Yeah,
about strength.
When you talk about all those things
that we try to say that we care about and
that we sometimes look to to be,
and very rarely can we be that
he was all that he was all of
that. And there it is right there.
I mean, how great is that?
And he stalked a guy.
He stalked a guy and his punches was
short and powerful and he was the greatest
finish in the history of heavyweight
boxing because when he hurts you,
you didn't survive. He got rid of you.
He put punches together and there was
short and he was always in position.
Look at his legs. He's always
in position. You move forward.
He takes a little step forward
back to give yourself rules.
Punches is absolutely beautiful.
If you wanted to teach a young fighter
how to punch correctly, Joe Lewis,
there's no better guy to watch than
cholo you saw. Did you see Joe,
what he did of our go? No a minute ago.
Smelling tried to catch them
with that same right hand.
He had knocked him out two years
earlier. Go back. They just missed it,
but he changed. He stepped out.
He changed his distance this
time because Jackie Blackburn,
who's a great fighter, a black
fighter, he was a trainer.
He was a great train and nobody hears
about Jackie Blackburn what a great
fighter he was and what a great trainee
was and how he wasn't allowed to fight
white fighters and he beat
everybody looked at cattle.
Love took instead of laying his head on
the right like he did the first fight,
he changed his range and he
made that right-hand miss.
Look how calm he is. Look how calm
he is. Look how focused he is.
It's beautiful. Watch shortness of
those punches. That's phenomenal.
I love watches legs. Joe. Watch. Watch
how he's always in position. Look at
what did we miss? What didn't
you see? Go back to sidestep. No,
the blinding jab that that sets it up.
We don't see what the
Jeb was just a Dick boy,
just so we can hit it with the
right so you don't see it. Right.
What a beautiful sidestep to right
after he lands a right hand. Beautiful.
Look at that. Well that's why he's the
greatest finish of all time. Watch,
watch, wait. He finishes this guy. What?
He's got to go to the body and the head.
Head to the body right ahead to
the head. Oh, that is so short.
And even when he's got the guy hurt,
look at the guy. Look at at phenomenal,
phenomenal.
And he did all of that with everything
we just talked about for the last 20
minutes hanging over him. Yeah.
He's a history that
people don't talk about,
but doesn't that make
you think a little bit,
doesn't it make you feel
something about us? Really? Yeah.
Well it's one of the reasons why I'm a
giants fan of the sport. Yeah. Thank you.
I mean that that alone is a, in
terms of like historical impact.
I agree with you. It's one of the biggest
moments in all of sports ever in life,
in life.